oh I didn't realize how wet wet my hair
looks apologies everyone you know we've
got our first ever done at me live
stream gotta look fresh ended up looking
damp
craziest weeks in the history of twitch
from gambling to Carlos and Andrew Tate
to chess drama to mizkiff we had it all
so in the interest of trying to cover
all of this news we couldn't just make a
donut at me every three hours so myself
and Danny Burke we decided to go live
over on our twitch Channel twitch.tv
slash the score Esports to break it all
down so before you watch this video go
give us a follow and then tune in now we
actually did a video covering
the start of this whole story
um through the week which if you
remember
was
um about a video that Carlos the CEO of
G2 also known as ocelot hosted online of
him partying in a club with Andrew Tate
I don't really think Andrew Tate needs
that introduction
but just in case you don't he's the the
bald guy who has uh sort of taken over
the podcast
um the board guy who was taking over
people's social media feeds he appeared
to be everywhere so he posts this video
with him and Andrew Tate at the club
there's not really any context for what
it's worth like we have no idea if they
went or at least I don't have any idea
if they went to the club together or if
they met there or if this was like you
know random pseudo internet celebrity
sighting and they just like started
partying together I I don't I don't know
the details of that basically there was
a lot of backlash on the internet
probably rightfully like uh you know
this guy has a horrible rightfully a
horrible reputation and Carlos is
someone who's seen as like you know the
representative of a massive company in
Esports so
Carlos kind of doubled down which I
don't know about you but I thought it
was kind of shocking to be honest it was
like he just yeah it was it wasn't it
wasn't just the the it was a doubling
down but also the um
the likes people were talking a lot
about his likes the kind of tweets that
he was liking in support of of the video
or and support or generally of entertain
perhaps um were pretty telling as well
that's what I found surprising and
people kept I saw people kept saying
this like why is why is nobody sort of
stopping him you know and what's what's
the structure of G2 where or maybe he
was just ignoring it right maybe there's
plenty of people who were messaging him
and telling him but he just you know in
his own words he party parties whatever
he liked so yeah I mean seriously yeah
perhaps rightfully so a lot of people
associ when when they saw Carlos
associating with Andrew Tate they drew
the conclusion that I mean he's a at
least is not uh he's he's I guess
amicable to his opinions enough that he
would be at a club with him again these
things they become extremely difficult
to actually arbitrate because we have no
idea how he ended up at the club with
him and you have no idea what they
talked about or whether they even talked
but if you're willing to post these
things on the internet then you're at
least willing to
um allow for public association with
somebody like that and with someone
who's been so outspokenly
brutal in the way that Andrew Tate has
and and kind of like basically is
unapologetically misogynist about almost
everything uh I think people drew the
conclusion that maybe Carlos was cool
with that like take traditional sports
right if if the owner of a traditional
sports team does something
you know offside they are absolutely
gonna get it's gonna go it's gonna make
the media cycle right Mark Cuban does
something yells at someone people are
gonna know but it's not necessarily
going to affect the people on the field
right which whereas like I think that's
where this the size of Esports really
comes into play and it being like a
relatively small
sort of community to be honest in in
terms of like scope this is the CEO a
guy who you know maybe maybe has had
three conversations with their Valerie
roster but
these these communities are small enough
and the teams and organizations are
small enough that the actions of this
guy can and will and have directly
influenced
um you know like in 18 19 20 year old
kids who are trying to like make it in
this uh in this like sort of weird
ecosystem whether whether you're a
public figure or a private figure like
you're you're still people are still
going to judge you based on The Company
You Keep like if you hang out with
losers people are gonna be like you're a
loser like even if even if you're a good
person or and and you mean well like
like The Company You Keep matters and
especially the company keep you keep on
the internet like Carlos isn't a stupid
guy he understands that when you
post something on the Internet people
are going to see it like how many
followers does the guy have he
understands what he did it was with her
his wording of like I draw my line here
into like that that was kind of odd
right he's like he's like I draw my line
here and all that was happening was
people were just giving him feedback on
a video he posted to millions of people
online he's like no I wrote my line here
so that was yeah I still think I still
agree that he understands it's just a it
was just very odd that he seemed shocked
right exactly like how could you how
could you possibly hit send on that
tweet and be like oh there's no way
there's gonna be any backlash on this
like the guy's just like the most
famously frustrating
[Music]
are very famously hated person on the
internet right now the fact that the
actions of this guy
are somehow going to impact like
valorant players and a whole Valor
ecosystem that they've developed
over time
is it seems like very extreme to me it
seems like very extreme that Carlos
popping bottles with Andrew Tate as
stupid as that is is going to impact
some kids that want to play Valor for a
living and that's going to be the
Fallout is that those because it's not
gonna be car the thing is is it's not
Carlos ever that is gonna that is gonna
get the worst of this I know he looks
emotional in that video but the guy is
still worth a lot of money he's gonna
have another business opportunity in
three days from now and the people that
are actually gonna get punished by the
fact that
potentially they're being left out of
Valor because of this are number one the
the G2 Esports employees that he's left
behind that have to clean up his best
number two these kids that want
to play valorant for a living that being
said yeah it does seem like
some of the news that came out today
is not true so earlier today there was a
report that
in the LEC uh that Carlos was forced by
Riot to
[Music]
um
sort of divest his ownership of G2
because obviously he would have had
shares in G2 there was a report earlier
today that that Carlos was forced to get
rid of his shares in order for G2 to
keep their uh franchise slot in the LEC
so this guy Riot to the max head of
Esports for uh emea
he or I guess League of Legends uh he
says that the LEC never requested Carlos
to resign or to divest his ownership
they've opened it at investigation still
ongoing but that report apparently is
not true or at least it's not coming
from riot because this this person he
also says here LEC didn't request Riot
did and he says no so that rumor today
seems to have been proven false or at
least that's what the the messaging from
Ryan is which is interesting given that
the same thing hasn't been said yet
about any of the Valor news from last
week hypothesizing for a moment what
would be
the best approach for right in this
situation and let's take is a given that
they don't want to continue
dealing with Carlos let's just say that
that part is non-negotiable right right
what would be the best way to to move
forward in the perhaps most uh with the
most empathy shall we say I mean I I
think maybe it was something a little
bit more prolonged like if if G2 was
already interested in distance
distancing themselves from Carlos or if
that was already planned based off of
this stuff and the announcement that we
saw like it's possible Right could have
spent some time talking to G2 before
they make a decision like that if that's
in fact what helped color that decision
I obviously I'm speaking assuming that
G2 Esports was a priority for the
European valorancing like given the
Legacy they have in in European Esports
also correct me if I'm wrong but do we
know for sure
that there's a there's like a one-to-one
link no no that's what I I've been
trying I've been I think pretty
consistently I I think like there is
there was a report on Friday that there
is that that people were saying
um that part of their decision to remove
or not have G2 in franchising was
because of this ongoing situation but we
don't we don't know for sure the only
thing we know for sure is that this
whole him being
him being held hostage for his shares by
Riot is not true because they they made
a statement on that today yeah so that's
that's the whole thing so you know
variable to come out and say uh
you know less than like you know the
what happened in the week with that
video was definitely a part of it but
you know we'd already made up our minds
that yeah
it would just be that would have been an
interesting end to this story wouldn't
it because it was like everyone has made
all these cases for and against based
off that yeah based off the fact that
link is is definitely real and uh you
know we don't technically know yeah I
mean it's very likely given given what
we've discussed already given like you
said their history and for sure um it
just seems so odd that they wouldn't be
included you know yeah they seem like a
complete showing for for it we'll be
coming back live on Twitch this
Wednesday I believe Wednesday or
Thursday Dimitri will be back talking CS
playing CS playing retakes uh by the
merch by the merch
I swear to God
um
I it was kind of a big passion thing for
me that I didn't want to make merch that
sucked because I think a lot of merch
sucks and the quality is low and I think
we did we did some cool stuff that's
simple and easy to wear but is also
pretty endemic so you guys are looking
for some new stuff please hit
shop.thescore.com yeah be on the lookout
for Dimitri on Wednesday we got uh don't
add me's coming to you all week and um
yeah we'll catch you next time thank you
yeah let's do this again yeah thank you
guys thanks for watching
bye
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock
[Music]